okay it's time to improve our hometown
app I'll go ahead and start with the
meta tag for the viewport on the Left
I've got the code that you started with
and on the right I've got my
modifications I added the meta tag with
the name viewport and then I set the
content to width equals device width and
the initial scale equals one okay well
that wasn't too hard let's see what's
next now I need to make some adjustments
to my CSS and markup so that everything
fits in a single column I'll be sure to
use relative widths to do so I'm going
to open up the page in dev tools and
make my changes there here's the page in
its original state
and now I've got dev tools open one of
the cool features of dev tools is that
when I hover over elements in the
elements pane I can also see them
selected on the page that's pretty
helpful when I'm hovering over the
header here I can see that the header
takes up the entire width of the
viewport so that seems pretty responsive
but I want to check out what's inside it
aha inside it I see this header inner
element and that's not taking up the
entire viewport like we wanted I think I
might need to make a change on the
right-hand side I can see header inner
CSS and its width is sent to a fixed 800
pixels that's not right I double-click
to change it and we'll change it to 100%
great now when I hover over it I see
that the header inner is the entire
width of the viewport so far so good
coming down on the page we come up to
the nav and when it's selected it's
pretty clear that it's not the whole
viewport width on the right side we can
see it's CSS and the width is set to a
fixed 800 pixels just like before I'll
set its width to 100% and now when I
select it it looks pretty clear that the
nav is now taking up the full viewport
width the header and the nav are looking
good I'll come down to main and once
again we can see that main is set to a
fixed width of 800 pixels now with width
of 100% I can see that the main is
taking up the entire width of the
viewport nice and side main content
looks good it looks like it's taking up
the full viewport but I want to take a
look inside too and now I see the
different sections on the page and
there's the hero now the hero seems to
of a fixed-width there's a lot of space
on the side I could take up but it's not
so I want to make a change its width is
set to a fixed 480 pixels and when I
change it to 100% we see it take up the
full viewport just like we wanted
looking down in the Dom I see the top
news section so I'll click on that and
once again it's obvious that the fix
width should be 100% or some other
percentage and not this fixed width okay
and now the top news takes up to the
entire width of the viewport that's good
I have to scroll down a little bit and
then I see sports and the scores aren't
taking up the full viewport if I click
on it I can see pretty clearly why right
here so once again 100% and now the
scores take up the full viewport not too
bad this has pushed the poor weather
section down really low and we've got
all this open space to work with so I
want to make sure it takes it up the
width right now is fixed at 320 pixels I
can change that to 100% and now the
weather takes up the full viewport very
nice and lastly the recent new section
is already taking up the full viewport
so hey not too bad don't have to do
anything there step one and step two are
done first step three I want to make
sure my touch targets are easy to hit
this means that I want my a tags to be
at least 48 by 48 pixels a tags remember
are going to be the touch targets
because the A's are the links to do so I
went through the CSS on the Left there's
what I started with and on the right
there's what I ended up with and I went
ahead and added a padding to the a tag
inside the nav class I set the padding
to 1.5 M which means that the padding is
equivalent to one and a half times the
font size of the a tag if I open up dev
tools and check out what I've done I can
see that the a tag here has a nice box
around it and its width is 69 pixels and
its height is 54 which means that it's
bigger than the 48 by 48 I was shooting
for that works for me farther down in
the page I see the top new
the item with an aid tag and I went
ahead and said it's padding 21.5 em as
well then I added the second one inherit
here that's going to be the left in the
right padding and it's inheriting the
padding from the item that is its
container with dev tools open it's
pretty clear the touch target there is
great good let's move on there's another
a tag inside the snippet title class so
once again we'll set its padding to 1.5
m and then of course one last time at
the bottom of the page there's an a tag
in the footer so one more change to the
padding let's take a look at the page
and it's full glory the page looks
really good on mobile I can scroll up
and down and see that all of the content
fits the viewport width we've got here
of course if the page gets a lot wider
than things start to get a little
ridiculous but that's okay now just to
be clear when you start comparing your
CSS to our CSS you might actually see
some differences between them and that's
okay there is more than one way to solve
this problem and in fact the CSS that I
ended up with in my main CSS file is
actually slightly different than the
changes I made inside dev tools dev
tools are a great place to start but of
course in the end you need to make your
changes to code and I well made a few
changes